Keck wie, keck keck wie, keck wie, keck wie, keck keck wie, keck wie, keck keck wie, größer null wie, null wie, keck wie, oh Gott, ich sollte lieber auf, das wird gleich wieder abgeschaltet,
ich stelle euch mal vor, random kommt hier irgendjemand ins Stream und das erste was er hört ist keck wie, keck, oh ne, bloß nicht, Grinch.
Oh, Avira Updated, warum habe ich den Kack überhaupt noch drauf, man, Avira, ich verstehe es immer noch nicht, also auch vom zweiten Rechner,
es liegt ganz einfach daran, weil ich den Rechner schon seit 6 Jahren oder so hier stehen habe und das hatte ich damals drauf,
Tribes 007, danke für den Sub, mit einem Mega Upload Song, oh ne, jetzt kein Mega Upload Song, also Leute, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt,
ja, würde mich mal interessieren, wo, schwierig, warum hast du überhaupt ein Antivirus, du hast wahrscheinlich auch ein Antivirus,
du hast Windows Defender, Windows Defender reicht auch, es gibt übrigens, ich habe letztens ein ganz gutes Video gesehen,
hat mich ein Kollege gefragt, also ein Kollege, Bekannter, auf Twitter gefragt, was ich von dem Video halte und ich fand das für Außenstehende eigentlich ganz gut,
gucken wir uns jetzt aber nicht an, Ultra,
Nativ oder so hieß der Typ,
Ultra Nativ,
das da, hat mir letztens einer geschickt, was ich von dem Video halte, muss ich sagen, war eigentlich so für Außenstehende echt ganz gut dargestellt, die Problematik,
so Leute, ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen daran gewöhnen, dass ich mich ein bisschen an Streamsoren wieder gewöhne,
ähm,
nachdem jetzt, ich will es ja nicht beschwören, Leute, ich will es ja nicht beschwören,
deswegen, ich muss, ich muss viel trinken und, und nicht so aufgeregt reden und so, nachdem jetzt mein Hals langsam, aber sicher, ich will es ja nicht beschwören, dass es wieder schlechter wird,
äh, besser wird, also die letzten, so die letzten paar Tage, würde ich sagen, war ungefähr schon gleich viele Tage, der Hals schlecht, genauso wie er okay war,
heute Nacht war nicht ganz so gut,
dafür war heute tagsüber ganz okay, also, ich, ich will es ja nicht beschwören, aber ich,
ich hoffe,
dass sich der Kram jetzt mal wieder erledigt hat, bald, ja,
danke für den Sub,
was für, nee, ich habe mir nichts geholt,
einzigem war es, ich habe, ich habe so, ich habe vom Arzt so Inhalationsding gekriegt,
was irgendwie hilft, dass das alles abschwillt,
und ich lutsch ab und zu mal,
ein Salbei-Bonbon. Und ich mach
einmal, zweimal täglich
äh, Dampf
mit, also
Wasserdampf mit
Salzlösung drin.
So zum Einatmen
auch zusätzlich. Das ist auch ganz gut für den Hals.
Aber sonst ist es wirklich so.
Ich mein, das ging jetzt über
drei Wochen. So lange hatte ich so einen Scheiß
echt noch nie. Vape Nation, genau.
Ich hab doch
jetzt, wo hier irgendjemand, Arch,
by the way. Irgendjemand
hat Arch, by the way. Ich hab letztens
unter einem Video
richtig dumm Arch, by the way
kommentiert.
Welches? War das
vielleicht sogar dieses Video hier?
Sekunde. Moment,
war das? War das vielleicht
sogar dieses Video? Sekunde.
Äh, hier findet man jetzt nix mehr.
Das könnte sogar dieses Video
gewesen sein, wo ich Arch, by the way,
kommentiert hab.
Äh, ja.
Hier kann man ja nicht gescheit suchen, ne?
Okay, wir machen jetzt,
wir machen jetzt Trick 17. Wir laden
jetzt einfach mal zwei Seiten YouTube-Comments.
Guckt euch das mal an. Wir laden
einfach ganz viel YouTube-Comments und jetzt suche ich mal
nach mir. Max,
nix gefunden. Okay, weiter.
Wieso hat YouTube keine Suche?
Weil die Usability von
YouTube einfach absoluter
Schrott ist.
Weil ich muss sagen, Leute,
ich merke das, wenn ich jetzt
sagen wir mal so, normale
Streaming. Ach, hier.
Ich benutze auch Arch, by the way.
Same.
Es hat keiner
gecheckt, dass es wieder ein Witz ist.
Hat wieder keiner
kapiert, Alter.
Endless Crawl, ja, cancer.
Arch, by the way.
Was, WiFi 7?
Wann ich erst WiFi
E oder sowas jetzt angesagt?
Ja, Endless Crawl ist
ganz grausam.
Wieso hat Twitch kein
Picture-in-Picture-Mode?
Also, in der App hat es
das und ich bilde mir ein,
in Firefox hat es, hat es das
in Firefox nicht auch?
Wartet mal kurz.
Leute, ich sag euch,
ich werde heute wieder nicht so lange
streamen, aber ich muss mich auch wieder dran
gewöhnen, so ein bisschen, ein bisschen labern,
normaler Lautstärke in
äh,
ne, tatsächlich, wenn ich zu
Gronkh rüber switche, ist das andere aus.
Ist ja klar, ne?
Ne, es gibt tatsächlich kein Picture-in-Picture.
Tatsächlich? Ja gut, ich meine, du kannst
wahrscheinlich mit FFZ oder so mit irgendeiner
Extension das machen, ja.
Bei YouTube geht's, ja.
Aber Brave ist ja auch Painschamp.
Also, es ist schon mal, es ist schon mal
angenehm, muss ich sagen. Jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt quasi,
also, tief ein-
und ausatme, dann kratzt
nicht mehr mein ganzer Hals. Ich bin ja,
bin ich ja schon froh drum, ja.
Nein, das ist immer noch nicht ganz gut und ich hoffe
wirklich, Leute, Prage, Leute, eine Runde
mal Prage in Chat für mich, please.
Das, das muss jetzt sein.
Dass der Scheiß sich jetzt langsam, aber
sicher erledigt.
Brauch jetzt eine Runde Prage-Spam.
Es ist kein Corona, Leute.
Es ist, es ist,
es ist kein Corona. Ja, danke,
Prage, Prage-Time.
Es ist kein Corona. Ich hab ganz viele Corona-Tests
gemacht. Also,
ich weiß jetzt übrigens, was es wahrscheinlich ist.
Kann ich, kann ich euch jetzt auch mal erzählen. Ich war jetzt ja
noch, noch mal bei meinem
Hausarzt. Ich hab gesagt, das, das
Funk geht nicht weg, das ist Mist.
Und der sagt,
dass das seiner Meinung nach
zwei Sachen sein könnten.
Also, als erstes hat er irgendwie gemeint, ich bin allergisch
gegen irgendwas.
Das kann nicht sein. Von heute auf
morgen irgendwie sehr merkwürdig, wie auch immer.
Ähm,
aber er hätte es weggehen müssen, ging es nicht weg.
So, und er meinte jetzt halt, entweder ist es
entzündet im Hals, das ist so, das machen,
das machen Ärzte generell gerne, nimm einfach
ein paar Antibiotika-Tabletten
und dann hoffen wir, dass es besser wird.
Oder er meint, was
auch sein kann, und das hab ich auch schon vermutet,
es kann sein,
dass, wenn man ein bisschen
Sodbrennen hat oder sowas in der Richtung, man muss das
gar nicht so extrem merken, aber es kann sein,
dass man nachts,
wenn man liegt,
ähm,
Dämpfe oder Magensäure
quasi,
äh, schluckt
oder einatmet.
Das klingt abartig,
aber
das reizt natürlich auch Hals und alles.
Also,
ja, keine Ahnung.
Richtig MonkaS, Alter.
Nein, ich war nicht beim HNO-Arzt.
Wenn ich zu, ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie ich das
machen werde. Sag ich jetzt mal.
Also, ich geh ja prinzipiell
am liebsten zu Ärzten,
wo ich selbst bezahlen muss, außer es ist
die MRT oder ich nicht gleich das laufend machen muss.
Also, ich muss es einmal in meinem Leben bisher machen.
Ähm, das ist ja teuer.
Das will ich nicht selbst bezahlen.
Aber ansonsten gehe ich ja mittlerweile,
wenn es schnell gehen muss, gerne zu Ärzten,
wo ich den Kram selbst bezahle,
wenn sich das im Rahmen hält.
So, was weiß ich, so, sagen wir mal, so unter 200, 300 Euro.
Ich muss ja auch nicht, ich muss, ich bin ja auch wirklich sehr selten beim Arzt.
Und dann geht das schnell.
Ich hab ja auch schon überlegt, ob ich mal irgendwo hingehen soll.
Man kann sich, man kann sich ja alles auch mal spiegeln lassen,
sogar mit, mit Betäubung,
dass man davon nicht viel mitkriegt.
Das ist alles halb so wild, aber eigentlich hab ich
da keinen Bock drauf. Alles ekliger Krame.
Ich hoffe, dass, ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, das legt sich so.
Ins Internet darfst
du ja prinzipiell nicht gucken.
Im Internet hast du ja gleich
Gehirntumor und Lungenkrebs immer.
Doch, doch, ich bin, ich bin,
ich bin nicht privatversichert. Ne, privatversichert
bin ich nicht.
Das hätte ich machen, das hätte ich theoretisch
mit 35 oder so machen sollen. Machen, machen.
Müssen. Auf der anderen Seite,
du bezahlst da halt massig Geld.
Ja, und
es ist im Prinzip ne Wette.
Es ist ne Wette, wie bei ner Lebensversicherung
oder so ein bisschen.
Ähm, oder was heißt, wie bei anderen
Versicherungen. Ja, du bezahlst, was du hoffst, es trifft
es, es tritt nicht ein.
Du brauchst es nicht, so nach dem Motto.
Ähm, auf der anderen Seite
halt, Krankenversicherung ist halt wirklich brutal
teuer. Also nochmal
mehr als das, was man eh schon an Abgaben
bezahlt.
Nur das, dass ich
eigentlich so gut wie nie brauche.
Ne, ich bin ganz
normal gesetzlich krankenversichert. Ich bin
doch nicht unversichert. Unversichert ist natürlich
Painschamp. Aber ich geh mittlerweile
ganz gerne, ähm,
zu Ärzten, wenn's nie was,
wenn's nie was, also, wenn's
nix Großes ist, wenn ich einfach will, dass es schnell geht,
bezahl ich das selbst. Leute, ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen, der Unterschied ist so groß, ne.
Ich hab mal angerufen,
bei, ich weiß nicht, das
könnte sogar ein HNO-Arzt gewesen sein.
Boah, ist schon ne ganze Weile
her. Hab ich, da hab ich gemeint, und, äh,
wie sieht's dann aus? Ich hab irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es war. Ich hatte
irgendwas. Ne, beim Hautarzt war das.
Ich hab beim Hautarzt angerufen
und hab gesagt, hier, ich hab irgendwie so ne,
so ne Entzündung oben aufm Kopf.
Äh, oder ich glaube, das, das könnte sich
entzünden. Ähm, das müsste sich mal jemand
angucken. Und wie's aussieht,
ob, ob ich nen Termin kriege.
Da meinte dann der Hautarzt zu mir so, also
die, die Sprechstundenhilfe meinte quasi,
ähm, mehr oder weniger,
zu mir.
So nach dem Motto, wie, ich will schnell
nen Termin haben. Lull. Hatte gemeint,
ja, so in nem halben Jahr. So in nem
halben Jahr. Und dann hab ich gemeint, okay,
also, es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten. Entweder
ist mir in nem halben Jahr der Kopf
abgefault, weil das wirklich was,
was, was Schlimmes ist.
Oder, ich brauch nicht mehr kommen.
Ist komplett sinnlos.
So, und dann hab ich einfach mal geguckt,
äh, Hautarzt Frankfurt,
äh, privat,
angerufen, und dann haben die
mich noch gefragt, ja, wann
passt's ihnen denn am besten?
Und seitdem ich das einmal gemacht hab,
hab ich
das jetzt schon öfters gemacht, für so
Kleinigkeiten, ähm, selbst bezahlt.
Und du bist sofort am Start. Du bist
instant am Start.
Es ist, es ist sogar eher so, dass die dich fragen,
ob das okay ist, wenn es
morgen noch, ähm,
reicht, ja.
Das ist ein Riesenunterschied.
Es, ja, ja, es ist, das ist absoluter
Witz. Absoluter Witz.
Und man muss tatsächlich sagen,
das ist auch aus finanzieller Sicht
manchmal gar nicht so blöd,
für den Hautarzt,
nicht Hausarzt, Hautarzt,
ich glaub, wie heißt das, der,
Dermatologe, ist das, Hautarzt?
Ja, ähm,
warte mal, äh, da, da,
was, ich wollte doch jetzt irgendwas, was, was anderes
dazu sagen. Ja, das ist halt lächerlich,
ja, gerade wenn du, wenn du irgendwas
mit Herz-Kreislauf hast, neun Monate
warten musst, dann ist die Sache die, du bist gestorben,
oder das ist wieder gut und du musst nicht hin.
Das ist halt witzlos.
Ja, aber was ich sagen wollte, es ist aus finanzieller Sicht
auch gar nicht so verkehrt,
ab und zu Sachen selber
zu bezahlen, weil,
ich würde, glaube ich, 250 Euro
mehr bezahlen im Monat,
wenn ich mich privat versichern würde.
So. Und,
also nochmal oben drauf,
zu dem, was ich jetzt schon bezahle.
Irgendwie so über den Daumen gepeilt, ich weiß es gerade aus dem Kopf
nicht mehr. Ich hab mich, ich, vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich da mal
geguckt. So. Und,
in der Regel brauchst du es ja
nicht, zumindest in meinem Alter noch nicht.
Und,
wenn du jetzt ab und zu mal sagst, hey, jetzt brauch ich
ein bisschen mehr Service, oder jetzt muss es mal ein bisschen
schneller gehen, wenn die Beträge nicht so
riesengroß sind, dann ab und zu mal
sagen, ich bezahl was selbst,
dann ist das gar nicht, gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ja. Immer noch besser als 250 Euro
jeden Monat auszugeben.
So, und zu der Frage, was ich beim Hautarzt
bezahlt habe, am Ende habe ich, glaube ich,
50 Euro
bezahlt? Ich glaube
50 Euro.
Plus, Minus.
Na gut, was heißt nur,
der hat ja nichts gemacht.
Der hat ja nichts gemacht.
Der hat da sein, oder die, die hat
da seine Lupe genommen,
hat auf meinen Kopf
mit der Lupe geloopt, das nennt man nicht
Lupe, das ist dieses Aufleucht-Ding,
wo man sich Sachen anguckt, hat sich das
angeschaut und hat gemeint,
ja, das wäre
ein bisschen entzündet und sie würde mir
einfach mal Creme aufschreiben, die soll ich
da drauf machen, gut ist.
Habe ich gemacht, gut war es.
So, fertig, 50 Euro.
Ich meine, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß,
für 10 Minuten gucken, 50 Euro ist
immer noch ein guter Stundenlohn, ja.
Naja, doch, doch, doch,
doch, doch. Also, es gibt zwei
Sachen, die ich festgestellt habe, die
man machen muss, wenn man selbst bezahlt beim
Arzt. Also, wenn du zu irgendeinem
privaten Arzt gehst, du musst zwei
Sachen machen. Du sagst
schon mal so grob, was du vorhast,
ja, und ob
die einschätzen können, einschätzen können,
so wie das preislich aussieht, meistens
können die so für die Standardsachen dir schon was
sagen und ganz wichtig,
ganz wichtig,
ihr müsst die fragen, mit welchem Satz
die abrechnen.
Es gibt so eine Gebührenverordnung,
nach denen sich quasi alle
privaten Ärzte
richten müssen
und das, was da drinnen steht, ist
der Basiswert.
Die meisten,
die meisten rechnen diesen Basiswert
2,3.
Das heißt, ihr bezahlt grob das 2,5-fache
von dem, was in dieser Gebührenordnung steht.
Hier, in diesem Ärzte
Gebührenordnung,
das Ding, das genau.
Da steht alles
mögliche drinnen.
Hier zum Download, zur Verfügung, ja genau.
Da stehen alle möglichen Leistungen,
die es bei Ärzten gibt, drinnen.
So, da steht zum Beispiel hier drinnen,
keine Ahnung,
was auch immer.
Ja,
Hornhautentnahme
aus einem Auge beim Toten,
zum Beispiel.
Alles klar.
Ähm,
kostet 13 Euro.
Also,
wenn ihr sterbt und bei euch muss
Hornhaut aus dem Auge entnommen werden,
kostet das 13,41 Euro.
So, und das ist die,
das ist die Base,
das ist die Basegebühr.
Die meisten rechnen das mal 2,3.
Ihr könnt ungefähr zweieinhalbfache rechnen.
Deswegen ist wichtig, dass ihr den Arzt
fragt, mit was der
standardmäßig für einen Satz abrechnet.
Die meisten sagen euch das nicht und kommen dann um die Ecke
mit Jagd. Bei uns ist es 2,3.
Aber ich hatte beispielsweise schon einen in Frankfurt,
der hat nur einfach abgerechnet.
Und da war auch nur insgesamt, das habe ich von
meiner Mutter gemacht, den Termin.
Die wurde insgesamt, lasst euch das mal
auf der Zunge zergehen, zweimal behandelt.
Und insgesamt waren wir
45 Minuten, also ich bin mitgegangen,
ich wollte ja gucken, für was ich da bezahle.
Insgesamt waren wir 45 Minuten
da drinnen.
Ultraschall,
Spritze, geguckt, gemacht, getan.
Insgesamt 45 Minuten.
Bei zwei,
und am Ende haben wir 105 Euro bezahlt.
So, hätte der
mit 2,3-fachem Satz abgerechnet,
hätten wir 250 Euro bezahlt.
Also das ist schon
ein Unterschied.
Ihr müsst auf jeden Fall mal grob fragen,
was kostet das?
Und ihr müsst die unbedingt fragen,
also wenn ihr jemals irgendwo hinwollt,
und selbst bezahlt beim Arzt, fragt den,
mit welchem Satz der abrechnet, standardmäßig.
Nicht, dass der um die Ecke kommt und sagt,
ich bin die krasse Super-Koryphäe,
ich rechne mit siebenfachem Satz ab.
Wobei das nicht geht.
2,3 ist das Maximale, es sei denn,
man weist euch darauf hin.
Wobei, das darauf hinweisen habe ich
rechtlich keine Ahnung, wie explizit
das erfolgen muss.
Ja, so sieht das aus.
Das ist in der Regel nicht unbedingt,
was es vorher insgesamt kosten wird,
aber, du kannst dem sagen,
also,
du sagst dem,
ja, du bezahlst selbst,
du willst wissen, was da auf dich zukommt.
Und wenn der Typ dann auf einmal anfängt,
so nach dem Motto, ja, jetzt machen wir erstmal Röntgen,
dann machen wir Ultraschall, dann machen wir,
dann machen wir da.
Also, der muss dir schon sagen,
was da auf dich zukommt.
Und das machen die in der Regel auch.
Das ist unglaublich groß.
Das hätte ich selbst nicht für möglich gehalten.
Wenn du privat zu einem Arzt gehst,
der hat Zeit für dich.
Das ist was, was man gesetzlich versichert
gar nicht wirklich kennt.
Die haben Zeit.
Die müssen nicht innerhalb von 10 Minuten
fünf Patienten durchgeschleust haben,
dass sich das irgendwie lohnt.
Die haben Zeit.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte ja beim Orthopäde
für meine Mutter einen Termin gemacht.
Und die war zweimal da.
45 Minuten Behandlung.
Einmal eine halbe Stunde, einmal eine Viertelstunde.
Und das war richtig gut.
Du konntest den Typ fragen.
Der hat erklärt, was er macht.
Der hat auch erklärt,
was er meint, was es ist
und was man jetzt dagegen macht
und wie das dazu gekommen ist,
worauf man bei der Bewegung achten muss
und sowas. Richtig gut.
Ohne Scheiß, dafür hätte ich sogar
das Doppelte bezahlt.
Nicht dieser Müll.
Das ist das beste Beispiel.
Die war im Krankenhaus
und hat sich dort untersuchen lassen.
Die hatte eine Entzündung an.
Ist ja auch egal, was es jetzt genau war.
Die war im Krankenhaus vorne
und hat sich untersuchen lassen.
Und dort wollten sie, dass sie
irgendeine Gelenk-OP macht.
Also zumindest wollten sie das quasi so.
Sie sagte mal, sie soll sich operieren lassen.
Und dann hat sie gesagt,
was ist das denn jetzt?
Und dann hat er sie weiter untersucht
und hat festgestellt, ach Mist,
das ist ja gar nichts, was man operieren kann.
Es wird zwar überall gesagt,
wir müssen in Deutschland aufpassen,
dass es keine Zwei-Klassen-Medizin gibt.
Das Problem ist, es geht hier nicht um Werden
oder so. Das ist schon so.
Das ist so.
Ich hab das selbst
oft genug jetzt gesehen mittlerweile.
Ich mach das schon die letzten
vier, fünf Jahre, dass ich
für Sachen, wo es schnell gehen muss,
selbst bezahle beim Arzt.
Es gibt Zwei-Klassen-Medizin und es ist
ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du zu einem Arzt
gehst, ich lass es gleich gut sein,
Leute, aber vielleicht ist das ein oder andere
für den das Thema ja ganz interessant.
Und dann kommen wir zum Raspberry Pi danach.
Wenn du zu Ärzten gehst,
die beides haben,
die gesetzlich Versicherte nehmen und
Privatversicherte, dann ist es eigentlich
fast immer so, dass
die zwei unterschiedliche
Schlaf...
Schlafzimmer, Alter.
Wartezimmer
haben.
Nicht nur, dass das für Private
meistens besser und bequemer ist,
darum geht es ja nicht, es ist hauptsächlich
deswegen, dass die gesetzlich
Versicherten nicht sehen,
wie viel schneller
Privatversicherte drankommen.
Weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das offiziell überhaupt darf,
aber es ist einfach so.
Es ist mega krass, der Unterschied.
Und ich kann euch nur empfehlen,
wenn ihr ein bisschen,
wenn ihr irgendwas habt, wo ihr sagt,
das müsste ich mal einen Arzt angucken,
der sich auch ein bisschen Zeit nimmt.
Und wenn es jetzt nicht gleich was ist,
was in die Tausenden geht,
überlegt euch nicht mal, ob ihr euch einen Arzt raussucht,
bei euch in der Nähe, der, wo ihr selbst
bezahlt. Ihr werdet sehen,
behandlungstechnisch und auch
mit dem Gut...
und dem Gefühl, wo man rausgeht,
dass man jetzt besser Bescheid weiß,
das ist das finde ich schon zum größten Teil
wert. Also kann man sich echt überlegen.
So, genug jetzt.
Das ist echt so. Du bist wirklich
krass. Es wird zwar immer gesagt,
wir müssen drauf gucken, dass das nicht passiert
und das kann ja nicht sein.
Da werden immer so fadenscheinige Dinge erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, nein, nein,
bei mir werden gesetzlich Versicherte
genau behandelt wie Privat. Das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht. Ich will nicht ausschließen,
dass es vielleicht nicht die ein oder anderen
Arztpraxen gibt, wo das so ist, aber
das, was ich bisher erlebt habe, war das nicht so.
Ja, es ist Wahnsinn.
Kann man, kann man.
Du kannst alle Arztrechnungen einreichen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von betrieblicher
Altersvorsorge? Gut, unabhängig.
Eigentlich wollte ich was zu Raspberry Pi erzählen
und wir wollten auch gleich was machen auf
Raspberry Pi. Also, der Stream hier hat zwei
Gründe, zwei Sachen. Erstens,
dass jetzt, wo mein Hals
hoffentlich präge, langsam wieder
ein bisschen besser wäre, dass ich mich ans Schwätzen
wieder gewöhne.
Und ich habe so lange nicht gestreamt.
Nee, nee, nicht Hyper-Gachi-Hals.
Wenn es Hyper-Gachi wäre, wäre ich ja froh.
Dann wüsste ich ja wenigstens, woran es liegt.
Ja.
Es war zu tief drin
oder so. Keine Ahnung, dann wüsste ich, woran es liegt.
Aber damit hat es nichts zu tun.
Ja, was hältst du von
betrieblicher Altersvorsorge?
Also, ich muss mal sowas immer dabei sagen.
Ich bin natürlich kein Experte und generell,
was stonks finanzielle Sachen angeht,
gibt es mit Sicherheit bessere Leute.
Ich kann euch immer nur erzählen, wie ich das handhabe.
Ich habe eine betriebliche Altersvorsorge,
weil,
das ist der einzige Grund. Ja, ich weiß,
dass ich mal was beim BWL gelernt habe,
aber da will ich nicht dran erinnert werden.
Ja, aus meiner
BWL-Ausbildung weiß ich zum Beispiel
noch, dass man linear und degressiv
abschreiben kann.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was der Unterschied ist.
Ich glaube, das eine ist langsamer
und das andere maximal mal drei
oder irgendwie sowas. Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt so ein paar Dinger, die habe ich mir gemerkt,
aber ich will davon eigentlich gar nichts mehr wissen
von dem ganzen BWL-Zeug.
Degressives Painstrap.
Ich weiß nicht mal mehr, was das ist.
Ach ja, und ich kann, das habe ich auch schon
recycelt, Recycled Story,
ich kann die Buchhalternase.
Die kann ich heute noch.
Wer die Buchhalternase nicht kennt,
das ist die Buchhalternase.
Das macht man, dass man
nicht mal faken kann. Also sprich, wenn
das hier abgeschlossen ist, macht man das hier drunter,
dass man nicht nachträglich noch Dinger reinschreiben kann.
Und eine Sache habe ich mir
aus meiner BWL-
Ausbildung auch
gemerkt, dass die Aussage
Erstemission
bei Aktien
nicht stimmt, weil
Emission bedeutet eigentlich immer nur,
also bedeutet immer Ausgabe.
Also im Prinzip würde dann Erstemission
sowas heißen wie
erste Ausgabe oder sowas.
Wobei
das mit Ausgabe ja schon drin ist.
Es gibt,
ich habe mir total sinnlose random Sachen
aus meiner BWL-Ausbildung gemerkt
und ich will damit auch nichts mehr
zu tun haben.
Das war echt früheres
äh
früherer Max, der das gemacht hat.
Das ist wirklich, ich
will mit BWL-Sachen nichts
mehr am Hut haben.
Wie läuft es denn mit Aktien?
Ja, wenn du Rheinmetall oder
Heckler & Koch gekauft hast, geht es ja wohl
ziemlich aufwärts gerade.
Ne, das ist nicht so.
Achso, vielleicht soll ich das hier erstmal beantworten.
Also, ich habe eine betriebliche
Altersvorsorge. Der einzige Grund,
warum ich das gemacht habe ist,
weil die Hälfte vom Arbeitgeber
bezahlt wird.
Also du kriegst quasi Geld zusätzlich.
Du kriegst, du kannst einen Teil
von deinem Gehalt dort überweisen
und du kriegst das quasi nochmal
zusätzlich obendrauf, was du so nicht kriegen würdest.
Und ich habe das damals auch
mit einem Honorarberater,
ich persönlich bin Fan von Honorarberater
und nicht von Honorarberatung
und nicht so sehr von ähm
äh Provisionsberatung,
weil die haben weniger Interesse daran
ihren Shit zu verkaufen.
Ähm, mit einem, das mal
gerechnet, der meinte, das lohnt sich.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die ich euch nur empfehlen kann.
Wenn ihr ein Angebot habt von eurem Arbeitgeber,
sucht euch mal irgendeine Beratungsstelle
und lasst euch, lasst euch
beraten. Es gibt ja mittlerweile genug Rentenberatungen,
die das machen.
Und fragt ihr mal, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Ja, aber das hier stimmt nicht. Also, wie gesagt,
Kleinigkeiten kosten auch nicht viel.
Also, ich wurde, ich wurde bisher, als ich selbst bezahlt habe
beim Arzt nur einmal gescampt
und das war tatsächlich in Frankfurt.
Ähm,
ja, auch wenn es jetzt ein bisschen eklig ist, ich erzähl das einfach.
Ich hatte irgendwie, mein Ohr
war irgendwie verstopft. Keine Ahnung.
Das muss man, muss man dann halt
sauber machen lassen, ja, dass es nicht mehr verstopft ist.
Das ist dumm, weil dann hört man auf einer Seite nichts.
Und
ich bin
dahin, hab da morgens
angerufen, hab gemeint, ja, ich kann in der Mittagspause
vorbeikommen, ging mega schnell.
Und am Ende haben die 70, 70
Euro abgerechnet. 70 Euro.
Und
die müssen natürlich schon eine Rechnung schreiben,
wo drauf steht, wie sich das zusammenrechnet.
Wie sich das zusammensetzt.
Da standen Dinger drauf, die überhaupt nicht stattgefunden haben.
Da stand drauf, mikroskopische
Untersuchung hat nicht stattgefunden.
Da stand drauf, irgendwie
Beratungsgespräch hat nicht
stattgefunden. Ähm, zig Sachen.
Da stand, da stand die Hälfte auf der Rechnung.
Ist nicht passiert.
Richtig getrollt, ja.
Scammed.
Scamast, Alter. Richtig heftig scamast.
Ja, das hat er zu mir auch
gesagt. Ist echt so.
Gerade wenn es was Dringendes ist, willst du
doch Bescheid wissen und nicht neun Monate auf einen
Arzttermin warten.
SelfmadeEyes, danke für den Sub.
Kann man mit Visual Studio Code gescheit C-Sharp
programmieren oder lieber Visual Studio
nutzen? Muss es unter Windows
sein?
Also, die Frage ist egal.
Benutz Rider.
Aber ja,
du kannst mit Visual Studio Code gescheit
programmieren, aber ich finde C-Sharp ist
etwas painstchampig zu programmieren
mit Visual Studio Code.
Also, nimm Visual Studio unter
Windows Community Edition.
Ansonsten, nimm Rider.
Guck dir die Trial-Version
an, wenn dir das gefällt.
Kannst dir das Bundle
kaufen, das ist auch nicht so teuer fürs Jahr.
Oder du bist Student, da kriegst du es kostenlos.
Oder aber,
du resettest deine Trial einfach
ab und zu. Das kannst du auch machen. Aber das will
ich euch nicht zeigen, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man das
eigentlich machen sollte.
Ich hab's mir gekauft.
Ich hab ein All-Desktop-Bundle von JetBrains.
Tja, so ist es. Das ist halt...
Naja, warum? Die haben das
gemacht, weil
das Geld bringt, sowas zu operieren.
Deswegen wäre ich doppelt und
dreifach skeptisch, wenn aus
heiterem Himmel irgendjemand was an mir machen will.
So habe ich das noch nie gesehen. Das ist richtig.
Das ist ein guter Vergleich.
So habe ich das noch nie gesehen.
Im Knast hat man Recht auf einen eigenen Raum
als Gesetzlicher im Krankenhaus
nicht.
Hat man im Knast ein Recht auf einen eigenen Raum,
ja?
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich sehe, hier sind die, hier sind die
Pfeifert-Leute.
New Heroic Proposal.
Was wird denn
proposed?
259.
T-Konten. Ja, das ist wirklich Monkagan.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern,
als ich meine Arbeit schreiben musste
zu Buchhaltungssachen,
wie man richtig saldiert.
Ist das Wort überhaupt richtig?
Nennt man das so? Saldieren?
Ich glaube, es hieß Saldieren.
Ein paar Sachen sind aus
meiner BWL-Ausbildung echt noch hängen geblieben.
Das ist aber schon ewig,
ewig, ewig her.
Das war mit
mit, keine Ahnung,
17 oder so.
Ja, kann ich mich noch daran erinnern,
da musste ich meine Arbeit schreiben und habe komplett
vergessen, wie der ganze Scheiß funktioniert.
Ich habe aber so einen mitleidigen Eindruck gemacht,
dass mir der Lehrer während der Arbeit
sogar gesagt hat, wie es funktioniert.
Kein Witz.
Ich habe da gesessen und habe
vor mir hingebastelt
und gedacht, es hat nicht funktioniert.
Und da meinte der Lehrer
irgendwann so nach dem Motto
ähm
und irgendjemand noch Fragen?
Und da habe ich gefragt, ja, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie es geht.
Und da meinte er so, ja, von hier nach hier
soll es gehen.
Wirklich viel gebracht hat es
mir auch nicht.
Ich hasse es. Also Buchhaltungssachen,
T-Konten mit Hand und sowas
ganz abartiges Zeug.
Hallo Max, ich habe
mich neulich für eine Stelle
Projekt System, was für ein Ding.
Das ist ja mal ein richtiger
Five-Hat-Move, Alter.
Du hast dich beworben und du weißt überhaupt nicht,
wovon du dich beworben hast.
Was stand denn da drinnen in der Stelle?
Da muss doch irgendwas drinnen
gestanden haben, was die haben wollen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Projekt
System Geschäft sein soll.
Also Projekt
Geschäft kann ich mir was vorstellen
darunter. Da wird gemeint, also Projektleitung
und solche Geschichten, also du beschäftigst
dich hauptsächlich mit Projekten, aber Projekt
System Geschäft, keine Ahnung.
Was sagt denn Wikipedia oder
denkst du dazu?
Projekt System Geschäft, English Translation
Ah
Portfolio Manager
Projekt System Geschäft
Ich habe keinen
Plastenschimmer.
Gut, Zahnarzt habe ich noch nie selbst bezahlt, weil ich
habe tatsächlich einen ganz guten Zahnarzt,
der auch gesetzlich Versicherte nimmt
und das gut macht.
Ich fand auch in der
Fachinformatik Ausbildung fand ich
BWL zum Kotzen.
Womit
kann ich am einfachsten ohne viel Aufwand
Projekte automatisiert auf einen Server deployen
und starten, vielleicht sogar automatisch bei einem
Wie wäre es mit GitHub Actions?
Je nachdem, ob
das intern ist oder nicht.
Ist das intern? Also die allereinfachste
Sache, die aller
allereinfachste Sache ist ein Post
ist ein
Github.
Ein Github auf irgendeiner
Also wenn du irgendeinen Repo machst, machst du einen Github.
Post, Post Receive
Hook.
Ähm
Nicht intern, ja dann nimm Github Actions.
Github Actions ist ziemlich easy
und kostenlos.
Aber die allereinfachste
Variante, auch wenn das
auch wenn das vielleicht
nicht mehr Web Native
Web 5.0
2022 gewollt ist,
ein Deploy Script
ist die einfachste Variante, wenn es
um eine überschaubare Anzahl an
Systemen geht. Deploy.sh
Da machst du dann
eine SSH Verbindung, killst den
Prozess, kopierst das neue
rüber, startest
den Prozess. Machst vielleicht vorher noch
irgendwas. Oder erstens das rüber.
Also
ich weiß, das ist nicht super krass
Agile Cloud Native
Mindset
Ey, du kannst auch mit
Ansible irgendwas machen oder so, ja. Aber ganz
ehrlich, wenn es einfach nur darum geht
das zu bauen, rüber zu
kopieren und dann da zu starten,
mach ein Deploy Script. Vor allem, wenn es nur
1, 2 Systeme gibt, worauf du schieben musst.
Wenn es
dann als Eingemachte geht,
quasi mit
Deployment hoch verfügbar,
also sprich, dass ein Load Balancer davor ist
und die Kisten nach und nach da hinten raus
fliegen, dann würde ich mir
tatsächlich was über GitHub Actions überlegen
oder eben über irgendeinen Ansible Job oder so
was. Oder wenn es im größeren
Stil ist, dann kann man sich dann auch mal was
überlegen, ob man irgendwelche
Container Geschichten macht.
Aber für eine Kiste,
wo ein Programm drauf läuft, Deploy.sh,
fertig.
Ich meine, du kannst immerhin auch,
wenn dir das nichts ist,
du kannst auch nach wie vor ganz
klassische Dinger wie nen Jenkins oder so
was verwenden. Ich bin
Fan davon, die Sachen nicht zu over-engineeren,
wenn es nicht sein muss. Auch wenn es
manchmal Spaß macht, gebe ich zu.
Manchmal macht es Spaß, einfache Dinge
quasi besonders extra
vagant zu lösen, aber
man muss die Sachen nicht verkomplizieren.
Also, wenn ich ein Service laufen
lassen will auf einer Kiste, brauche ich kein Kubernetes
Cluster. Und ich brauche auch
kein Grafana
Prometheus Monitoring
und ich brauche auch kein
Continuous Integration
Server und
irgendwelche sonstigen Dinger.
Ich baue das Ding, ich rsync oder scp
das rüber, restarte den Service
und gut ist.
Und das mit irgendeinem Deploy-Skript ist wahrscheinlich die einfachste
Variante. Doch! Ja, ich weiß, der Chat braucht
das nicht.
Echt nicht? Ach stimmt, das ist ja mittlerweile
an Accounts gebunden. Da musst du dir
mal Fake-Accounts machen, ist auch nicht gut.
Wobei, so ein Fake-Account alle 30 Tage kann man
auch machen.
Ich hoffe, der Endpunkt
guckt nicht zu.
Mit dem Endpunkt wollte
ich sogar demnächst mal streamen, wenn uns ein Thema
einfällt. Er ist ja mittlerweile
richtig krasser IT-Consultant.
Und da könnt ihr,
haben wir uns gedacht, wir machen einfach mal einen Stream,
wo die Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, ihnen ein bisschen
was fragen können oder generell so.
Geschichten in der Richtung.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Meine Meinung zu .NET Blazer Server.
Tja, ganz ehrlich,
ich bin kein großer Blazer-Fan.
Ich
weiß nicht, was die
Leute daran so geil finden.
Ich mein, prinzipiell verstehe ich, du kannst
.NET C-Sharp verwenden für
Backend und Frontend. Blazer Server
ist dann so die Kombination aus beidem
über irgendeine WebRTC-Websocket-Verbindung,
den UI-State
synken.
Ich weiß nicht.
Denke mal nicht, dass du
Lust hast, darauf hast, dir das anzuschauen.
Aber die Stellenanzeige findet man sofort, wenn man nach Projektgeschäft googelt.
Ist von Rolls-Royce.
Poggers.
Da hast du dich drauf beworben. Doch, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Rolls...
Royce.
Okay.
Wo ist das?
Projekt-System-Geschäft Rolls-Royce.
Ne, findet man nicht.
Praktikant. Das da?
Portfolio-Manager.
Das da.
Das da?
Wobei, wobei.
Wir gucken einfach in Google.
Wir gucken einfach in Google-Cache.
Du wurdest auf Vorstellungsgespräch
eingeladen. Ja gut, kann ja sein, dass du auch nicht genau bist.
Also, was wollen die dann haben?
Praktikant. Ne. Hä?
Wait a minute.
Hab ich das falsche aufgemacht?
Ja, ich hab das falsche
aufgemacht. Ah, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Ja, dann kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Und Blazor selbst, also
quasi .NET im Browser über
WebAssembly. Das letzte Mal, wo ich mich
damit beschäftigt hab, hat es ewig gedauert, bis es
startet. Und ich muss
sagen, ich bin mittlerweile mit JavaScript
halbwegs warm geworden. Ich wüsste nicht, warum ich sie
sharp im Browser verwenden will.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Ja, warum nicht? Es gibt tatsächlich
relativ viele Lösungen, die auf Raspberry Pi basieren
mittlerweile.
Ich habe drei Tage Zabbix-Schulung
gehabt. Boah, es ist jetzt Zabbix 6
rausgekommen, vor ein paar Tagen.
Verwendet jemand von euch Zabbix 6 schon?
Ist erst letztens
erschienen.
Okay, vor drei Wochen.
Zabbix,
wie die coolen Leute dazu sagen. Nicht hier einfach
Zabbix. Zabbix.
Abo da, Leona, boah, aber dankeschön für den
Zapp. Hoffentlich
ein besserer Consultant als die Dame aus dem
Video. Du meinst, das Video, wie viel
verdient ein IT-Consultant oder sowas,
was wir letztens geguckt haben. Ach, du meinst,
ah, jetzt weiß ich es wieder. Du meinst,
die, die Excel-Listen kopiert hat den ganzen
Tag. Ja, ja, ja.
Also, ich habe ja, ich habe ja über
Herr Endpunkt ein bisschen abgelästert in meinem
Azubi-Video, aber
er hat definitiv mehr Plan,
als die Excel-Schubsfrau
aus dem Video. Ja.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt?
Ne, habe
ich nicht. Kein Recycle-Story.
Dass ich jetzt zum ersten
Mal vor, vor zwei
Wochen oder so, Geld verdient
habe mit einem, ich nenne es mal
Freelancing
Programmier-Job.
Das ist jetzt viel übertriebener, als
es, als es ist, ja.
Jemand Bekanntes hat mich gefragt, ob ich für sie was
basteln kann.
Habe ich gemacht und am Ende habe ich ein bisschen was für gekriegt.
Also, aber kann
ich jetzt gleich mal in meinen Lebenslauf schreiben?
Programmier-Freelancer.
Du musst wirklich nur nach
Projektsystemgeschäft googeln.
Ja.
Das da, Xing, das da.
Da hast du dich beworben, okay.
Achtung, Flashbang.
Was ich gebastelt habe,
ähm,
ich habe ein, äh,
Azure Active Directory,
eine GraphQL
API mit
Azure Active Directory
Identifizierung
gebaut.
Projektmanagement-Standards, iiih.
Beratung,
Coaching und Schulung vor dem Projekt.
Ach, ist das das Falsche, was ich, was ich aufgemacht habe?
Das da muss ich aufmachen. Moment, Moment.
Was da?
Moment,
warum klettern die denn da rum?
Ich dachte Rolls-Royce macht Autos und, und Turbinen
und sowas. Ich wusste nicht, dass die irgendwas mit klettern.
Oder, ne, ich glaube,
das Klettern soll einfach nur zeigen, dass sie so krass
agil sind dort, dass man da auch klettert.
Die, die Story mit dem
Kletterpark auf der Arbeit habe ich auch schon erzählt,
oder? Ja, habe ich, habe ich glaube ich schon mal gemacht.
War auch so, so ein
PaintChamp Projektmanagement-Idee.
Dezentrale Energieanlagen.
Da steht
ja gar nichts.
Da steht ja nicht wirklich was, oder?
Ich meine, dass man als Werkstudent
Student sein muss, das hätte ich nicht mehr denken können.
Sicherer Umgang mit Office.
Unternehmerisches Denken.
Flexibilität
zu mobiler Arbeit. Arbeiten an verschiedenen
Standorten. Reisetätigkeit.
Da wäre es für mich schon vorbei.
VBA.
MonkaS, Alter.
Erstellung technischer, kommerzieller
Präsentationen und Berichte.
Wahnsinn. Es gibt Jobs, die
hauptsächlich Powerpoint machen, ja?
Wirklich?
Dokumentenvorlagen.
Meine Güte.
Ja, viel Spaß.
Rezerif, danke
für den Sub.
Primesum. Ey, du gehst einfach
über den Sub-Button und dann drückst
du drauf und dann kannst du auswählen, ob du
subben willst, normal oder primesub.
Habt ihr dieses
Gerichtsurteil gesehen, wo letztens
einer vom Weg quasi vom
Schlafzimmer ins Arbeitszimmer
aufs Maul gefallen ist und das war
ein Betriebsunfall?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das ganz richtig wiedergegeben
habe, aber so in der Richtung war
es. Der ist irgendwie auf
dem Weg quasi zu seinem Homeoffice-Arbeitsplatz
hingefallen
und es ist ein Betriebsunfall.
Visual Basic Script ist
auch bei der Testautomatisierung
mit UFT noch voll aktuell.
Was ist UFT? Kenne ich nicht.
Das geht
nicht. Ist dein Prime abgelaufen
vielleicht? So geht das.
POG.
Gamepad, danke für den Sub.
Power BI.
Welche? Gar nicht.
Das ist ein Azure-Dienst. Hat mit
Office 365 nichts zu tun.
Ach nee,
du meinst, was man
für eine Office-Lizenz braucht, damit man das
anbinden kann, sein Office an Azure AD
kein Schimmer. Damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Damit will ich mich auch nicht auskennen. Das ist mir zu
Microsoft-heavy.
Ja, also jetzt mal
zum Raspberry Pi kurz mal hier.
Ich habe mir einen Raspberry Pi
gekauft, weil ich habe
meinen letzten Raspberry Pi, also den letzten
Vierer, den ich hatte, habe
ich ja verwendet als Ablöse
im Wohnzimmer für meinen TV-Head-End-Server.
Also
die, wo Fernsehaufnahmen und so drauf gemacht werden.
Mit TV-Stick.
Und ich habe
ewig gesucht.
Raspberry Pi.
Hatte
Guidescience nicht normalerweise Autocomplete?
Achso.
Alter.
Wie lahm war denn das gerade?
Lull.
So, und das einzige, was ich noch
lieferbar gefunden habe, ist
äh
Konnte man denn nicht
sagen, lagernd? Irgendwo?
Lagernd?
Rechts?
Aber hier in der Übersicht nicht, ne?
Naja,
zumindest das einzige, was ich gefunden habe,
ist ein Raspberry Pi 4
8 GB
lagernd
bei
einem österreichischen
Shop.
Das ist das einzige, was ich gefunden habe.
Aktuell gibt es hier überhaupt keinen
mehr. Krass. Ich habe wohl den letzten
bekommen. Hier ist auch alles weg.
Hier ist auch alles weg. Heftig.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
So.
Na, Ebay ist auch nicht
billiger. Wir können ja mal kurz gucken.
Wieso sind die so teuer?
Weil alle Chip-
Geschichten teuer sind. Ja, 90
Euro. 90 Euro,
Alter, für ein 2G-Modell.
Das kostet normalerweise 40.
So.
Und was ich jetzt gekauft habe, ich habe jetzt bei einem
österreichischen Shop bestellt.
SemAF
AT.
Habe ich vorher noch nie gehört.
Aber schlechtes WLAN hat per Prime
satt. Na gut, zum Glück
klappt die Verbindung zu Twitch.
Jetzt habe ich hier was bestellt
und zwar die hatten aber auch nur
noch
den Vierer
da.
Mit 8G
Ja, ein Zero 2W
mag sein, aber kein Raspberry Pi 4.
Und jetzt habe ich den bestellt
mit dem offiziellen Netzteil
und einem Case
und da bin ich bei 120 Euro.
Und ich, dafür ist das
gar nicht so extrem teuer.
Das ist preis-leistungstechnisch
fast, fast
am normalen, an der normalen
Preisempfehlung. Ich habe tatsächlich die letzten
gekriegt von denen.
Wahnsinn. Ich habe die letzten bestellt.
Hatte ich nur mal Glück gehabt.
Da hatte ich
noch mal Glück.
Was du mit dem Raspberry Pi machen willst, also mit dem
jetzt, den will ich
einfach nur haben für
Sachen,
die ich basteln will, beziehungsweise
für Sachen, die wir im Stream machen
wollen. Ich habe keinen mehr,
keinen Vierer. Und ich brauche mindestens
einen unbenutzten Vierer, wenn ich halt mal
was brauche.
Also sprich, wenn
wir Steckdosenleisten flashen wollen,
wenn wir irgendwas auf Raspberry Pi
ausprobieren wollen, vielleicht, wenn wir mal
irgendwelches Elektronik Zeug im Stream wieder machen
wollen. Ich brauche
einen unbenutzten Raspberry Pi Vierer
daheim, mit dem ich was machen kann.
Ebay Kleinanzeigen?
Ernsthaft?
Ich habe noch nie Ebay Kleinanzeigen
verwendet.
Okay, okay.
Das ist doch gmail, Alter.
Jemand Ideen für Raspberry Pi?
Ne, wenn du keine Ideen hast,
ich habe auch keine Ideen. Ich meine, ich kann dir sagen, was ich
damit mache, aber das wird dir wahrscheinlich nichts bringen.
Also ich habe einen für meine
Kameras.
Zum Einsammeln der ganzen Feeds.
Ich habe
einen Unify Controller drauf.
Ich habe einen
für den 3D Drucker.
Ich habe unten im Keller einen
für die Tür-Gegensprecher
Anlage.
Zeros.
Unter anderem für die Kamera am
Hoftor.
Ja, Kubernetes.
Zum Üben daheim mag das nice sein,
aber sonst braucht keiner ein Kubernetes Cluster auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das ist Absicht.
Also, das erste ist,
bei manchen Sachen musst
du vor Ort sein. Also den Raspberry Pi
im Keller, der muss im Keller
stehen, weil im Keller ist die Heizung,
im Keller sind die Kabel von der Tür-Gegensprecher
Anlage.
Die Hoftor Kamera,
die ist auch am Hoftor.
Also manchmal musst du vor Ort sein.
Und warum ich sonst die Sachen mittlerweile
ein bisschen aufgesplittet habe, liegt daran.
Ich hatte, warte mal.
Also als ich dieses Video hier
erstellt habe.
Ist das noch ein altes?
Oh ja, Kabel-Saal. Oh, das ist das
ganz alte.
Hier. Also,
zu dem Zeitpunkt
hatte ich auf dieser Kiste hier oben
so ziemlich alles
laufen, was es bei mir gab im
Haus.
Alles. Inklusive Internetzugang.
Da hatte ich noch einen PFSense-Router
damals drauf. Das Problem
war nur, ich konnte
diesen Server nicht anfassen.
Weil egal was ich gemacht
habe, also wenn ich gesagt
habe, ich muss mal Ubuntu updaten, restarten,
was auch immer. Irgendwas ging dann halt
im Haus nicht. Da ging die
Rollläden nicht mehr oder die Fernsehaufnahmen
waren aus oder das Internet
war weg.
Also, das war ein riesen
Single Point of Failure, der
auch mega beschissen zu warten war.
Daraufhin habe ich gesagt, weißt du was?
Warum mache ich es nicht einfach
ein bisschen weniger sophisticated
und habe das aufgesplittet.
Ich habe im Wohnzimmer eine Kiste liegen für
Fernsehaufnahmen jetzt. Ich habe
eine Kiste am 3D-Drucker, die für einen 3D-Drucker
zuständig ist. Ich mache Internetgedöns,
Netzwerkgedöns über meinen MikroTik-Router
mittlerweile.
Und dementsprechend,
wenn ich jetzt meinen Server neu starte, ist
mal das Samba weg, mein Wiki
geht nicht oder solche Geschichten.
Aber die Rollläden gehen wenigstens
noch auf und zu.
Ja, das ist der Grund, warum ich den Kram nicht alles auf einer
Kiste habe. Und ich bin der Meinung, das ist
der bessere Ansatz, als alles auf einer
Kiste zu machen. So, eBay Kleinanzeigen.
eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Raspberry Pi.
Guck mal!
105 Euro! Alter!
40 Euro!
160 Euro!
100 Euro für
einen 2G mit einem Netzteil!
140 Euro!
90 Euro!
Alter, das ist brutal!
Das ist mega-ultrateuer!
Dann ist das ja fast noch günstig!
Der 3D-Drucker kostet alleine mehr
und der Raspberry Pi ist mit drinnen.
Ja. Alter!
Was für Preise! Guckt euch das mal an!
Da müsste man jetzt
hinschreiben, was für ein letzter Preis!
Ein Starterkit
für 240 Euro!
Leute!
240 Euro!
Ne!
Da bin ich wirklich ganz gut gefahren!
Ihr guckt euch das mal an!
Ich habe
jetzt
120 Euro bezahlt!
Best Raspberry Pi
4 Case!
Das offizielle Netzteil!
120 Euro ist durchaus
in der aktuellen
Zeit
ein guter Preis!
Ich weiß gar nicht,
was ist denn der Pi4
UVP?
Nein, USB-UVP!
Haben die
sowas überhaupt?
Ich glaube 70 Euro oder so
ist für das 8G-Modell!
Zumindest den habe ich mir jetzt bestellt!
Ist heute angekommen und
jetzt habe ich endlich wieder
einen Raspberry Pi 4 auf Lager
für wenn wir im Stream was machen wollen!
Und eigentlich wollte ich heute im Stream nur mal
schnell gucken, ob USB-Boot
mittlerweile einfacher ist!
Ich habe ja durch meinen
NAS-Bau, durch diese Android-Geschichte,
die wir hier im Stream gemacht haben, noch jede
Menge externe SSDs rumliegen!
Wollte gucken, ob USB-Boot mittlerweile
einfacher ist! Weil wir haben ja das letzte Mal
USB-Boot ausprobiert, da war das
wirklich noch experimental!
Da musste man irgendwelche Grub-Einträge
von Hand machen, dass das funktioniert!
Können wir mal ausprobieren!
Moment, ich brauche einen neuen Router!
Hast du eine Empfehlung für mich?
Das kommt drauf an!
Die Antworten sind
leider nicht so einfach!
Willst du wirklich einen Router?
Oder willst du ein
Multifunktionsgerät in Richtung Fritzbox?
Also soll das den Internet-Einwahl
machen? Soll das, keine Ahnung,
Kinderschutz-Features
haben? Soll das
Smart-Home-Steuerungsmöglichkeiten
haben? Soll das USB-NAS-Geschichten
haben? Soll das
WLAN haben?
Also bist du jetzt auf der Suche nach einem
Multifunktionsgerät, sowas wie eine Fritzbox?
Oder suchst du, deckt, deckt
Basisstation, oder suchst du
wirklich einen guten Router?
Wenn du mir das sagst, kann ich dir wahrscheinlich auch
was empfehlen! Ansonsten, wenn du Multifunktionsgerät
suchst, hol dir eine Fritzbox!
Es ist zwar die rote Pest
aus Berlin, aber die Fritzbox-Dinger
sind, auch wenn sich da
lustigerweise an vielen Stellen, gerade
von irgendwelchen selbsternahen Netzwerkexperten
drüber lustig gemacht wird, sind,
die Fritzbox-Dinger für den Heimgebrauch
und vor dem Komplettpaket
eigentlich das Beste, was du dir holen kannst.
Ja, AVM,
die haben noch so ein rotes Logo und kommen
aus Berlin.
Das hat sich irgendwie mal so eingebürgert, das zu nennen.
Eigentlich sind die Dinger nicht schlecht.
Dezentralisierung,
genau.
Muss man bei der Ausbildung Fachentwicklung...
Doch, musst du!
Klar musst du programmieren in der Ausbildung.
Die Ausbildung zwischen Systemintegration
und Anwendungsentwicklung ist jetzt nicht so unterschiedlich.
Du hast auch Programmieren
in der Berufsschule.
Ob du das auf der Arbeit machen musst
oder nicht, hängt ganz davon ab, was du machst.
Aber
die klassische Sache
Systemintegration ist ja
Richtung Serveradministration,
wobei reine
Allschool-Serveradministration ja eigentlich immer weniger wird.
Also das geht halt auch
mehr in die Cloud-Richtung
oder
dass du dich um irgendwelche
Entwicklertools oder was auch immer noch mitkümmerst.
Und da die ein oder anderen
Scripts programmieren können, ist nicht
verkehrt, damit man seinen Job gescheit machen kann.
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich
weder in der Ausbildung noch
im fertigen Job, es sei denn du bist Windows
Active Directory Wizard-Durchklicker,
nicht daran vorbeikommen, ein bisschen
zu programmieren.
Kann man alles machen.
Ja, Grafikkarten sind billiger geworden.
Guckt mal.
30, 90
TI... Ach nee.
30,90
Strix
Preisentwicklung
Guckt hier.
Die Preise sind...
Ich muss vielleicht eine andere Grafikkarte nehmen,
aber die Grafikkartenpreise sind ein wenig
gefallen. Guckt mal hier.
Hier war man zwischenzeitlich auf fast 3000 Euro
und jetzt sind wir wieder runter auf 2349.
Strix Rock
Strix
Schauen wir mal nachher ein bisschen was.
Ein bisschen
verbreiteterem, sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Was Super Skyrim... Ach nee.
Super...
Warum habe ich denn Super Skyrim gelesen?
Ja, guckt mal hier, Leute.
Richtig, richtig
getroppt von
2300 auf gestern
1679.
Fuckchamp.
Ich meine, es ist immer noch
wahrscheinlich
30 Prozent
oder über dem normalen Preis,
wie es eigentlich sein sollte.
Ist halt so.
Generell frage ich mich,
für was eBay Kleinanzeigen gut ist.
Ja.
In England werden ja Raspberry Pi's
quasi wie Brötchen verkauft.
Haben die nicht sogar Raspberry Pi Stores
in England?
Eigene?
Ja, genereller Chipmangel.
Liegt jetzt nicht speziell am Raspberry Pi selbst.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ach!
Ist das jetzt offiziell raus, das 64-Bit-OS?
Ich habe letztens noch 32...
Moment, das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken.
Ich starte mal die VM.
Dann machen wir das jetzt noch schnell.
Gute Raspberry Pi.
Probieren wir mal USB-Boot, sage ich aus.
Porgas VM wird gestartet.
CPUs sind übelst günstig.
Ja, das bringt ja nichts,
wenn der Rest mega teuer ist, ne?
Warum ist der Beruf SAP-Consultant
bei IT-Land so unbeliebt?
Ich glaube, das liegt daran,
weil das ist so ähnlich,
wie, dass man sich über Java lustig macht.
Es ist nicht wirklich schlecht
oder so.
Man kann sich nur gut drüber lustig machen.
Und über Consultants
mache ich mich auch gerne lustig,
weil leider kenne ich sehr viele Consultants,
von denen ich jetzt persönlich nicht wüsste,
zu was ich sie konsultieren würde.
Aber die trotzdem massig
Kohle absahnen.
Wir machen nur noch C-Sharp und Python
überwiegend bei uns in der Berufsschule.
Kein C++, ja, dann sei mal froh.
C++ ist ja auch die beschissenste
Programmiersprache, die es gibt.
Da programmier ich ja fast lieber
Brainfuck oder so.
Redstone programmieren.
Ich programmiere lieber Redstone,
bevor ich C++ programmieren, ja.
Ist das Aldi Talkum
oder Online-Katalog?
Ne, das ist Lidl.
Lidl ist das.
Da wollte ich mir mal irgendwo
eine Steckerleiste kaufen,
weil ich ausprobieren wollte,
ob die sich pairen lässt mit
Zigbee2MQTT.
Ach ja, was war denn jetzt eigentlich
da?
Wer hat denn das geschrieben mit dem
Router?
Hier, Benzeman.
Benzeman, hast du noch was geschrieben?
Sieht nicht so aus.
NO GOD!
NO GOD, PLEASE NO!
NO!
Die Firmen haben sich bei uns
in unserer Berufsschule, dass wir
outdated stuff wie C++ lernen.
Ja, C++ ist ja nicht wirklich outdated.
Und C++ hat ja auch
laufend irgendwelche neue Sachen.
Aber die Komplexität bei C++ ist
leider so groß mittlerweile, dass du
diese Sprache gar nicht lernen kannst
gescheit, ohne dass du dein Leben
dem C++-Gott
opferst.
Keine Fritzbox mit USB-C.
Ist doch egal.
Warum brauchen das Ding USB-C?
Hä?
Ja, genau, den Niederländern opfern.
So sieht's aus.
Es gibt tatsächlich, dafür gibt es
auch viele oldschool C++-Libraries
für jeden Scheiß, die es woanders nicht gibt.
Das Problem ist nur, dass C++ halt noch mit
Header-Files rumhantiert.
Und solche oldschool Shit.
Bis Module mal irgendwann in allen Compilern
richtig unterstützt werden, dauert eh schon wieder
drei Jahrzehnte. Und bis dahin
sind ja bei weitem nicht alle Libraries
umgestellt da drauf.
Wie relevant ist Lisp eigentlich noch?
Nicht mehr wirklich relevant.
Außer du verwendest Emacs.
Wer auch immer das noch macht.
PHP ist nicht verkehrt zu lernen.
Ganz ehrlich...
Ganz ehrlich.
PHP ist besser als...
USB-C für externen SSD.
Dann nimm doch einfach USB auf USB-C.
Hol dir nen Kabel, USB-Typ A
auf USB-C. Fertig.
Steck's in die Fritzbox.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
ähm, nass-technisch
wird ne Fritzbox
keine großen Performance-Sprünge machen.
Auch mit ner SSD nicht.
Das ist cool, ja.
Wahrscheinlich ist das sogar gültiger.
Leute,
das ist gültiger C++-Code, oder?
Ne, das Auto geht nicht. Also das geht.
Das ist Return-Wert.
Das ist Funktionsname.
Das ist erster Parameter-Typ.
Und das ist erster Parameter-Name.
Ich glaube, dass das Auto
an der Stelle geht nicht, oder?
Aber das hier wäre gültiges C++.
Randomfrage.
Edge, Chrome, ja, nein.
Nö, warum?
Gibt doch zig Milliarden andere Browser.
Es sei denn, es gibt für dich ein
Feature bei Edge, was dafür spricht.
Ja, Golang-Enjoyers
gibt's tatsächlich ein paar.
Ich find ja Go
auch gar nicht mal so mies.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hab zwischen
C++ oder Go,
auch wenn's nicht wirklich große
Überschneidungen hat, aber
dann eindeutig Go.
Aber es gibt in Go auch viele Sachen,
die ich fragwürdig finde.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mittlerweile mit Generics in Go aus?
Ist das mittlerweile
gelandet?
Ich mein, die sagen seit drei Jahren schon,
dass Generics bald da sind.
Nein, Kotlin hab ich
keine Ahnung. Aber
ganz ehrlich,
wenn du CC Sharp
kannst, sollte Kotlin ganz gut sein.
Vor allem, was ich gehört hab. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
ich würde gar keine Native
Entwicklung machen für Android.
Wenn ich ne App entwickeln würde,
dann würd ich's mit sowas wie
React Native oder
ähm
Wie heißt das mit I am Anfang?
Ich hab's grad vergessen. Ionic.
Oder sowas machen, weil
dann kannst du, dann sieht das
naja, Flutter auch nicht.
Ich würd React Native oder Ionic
oder wahrscheinlich würd ich Ionic verwenden.
Ionic mit View oder irgendwas drunter.
Und
ähm
dann würd ich ne App machen, die auf
beidem läuft und auf beidem gut funktioniert.
Ja klar!
Wir haben ja auch schon ESP32
C++ gemacht, aber trotzdem
ich hasse C++.
Search and Replace sind doch Generics.
Also das muss man C++ tatsächlich lassen.
Mit Templates hat C++
theoretisch den besten
Generic Support von allen Sprachen.
Wo du Sachen
machen kannst mit
Compile Time Checks,
die so in anderen Sprachen nicht möglich sind.
Aber dementsprechend
ist es auch abartigst
wirr.
Na du kannst zum Beispiel in C++ zur
Compile Zeit checken, ob
keine Ahnung, Parameter 1
ein Character Array
als Parameter übergeben wird,
das länger als 15 Zeichen ist und dann
einen Compiler Fehler schmeißt und sowas.
Das fällt mir keine andere Sprache ein, wo sowas
geht. Ist cool,
aber
ja.
Ionic is Pain, weiß ich nicht, habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Das einzige, was mir jetzt eingefallen ist,
wo ich mal ein Tutorial zugeguckt habe.
Ja gut, PWA kannst du ja in allem
machen.
Machst du ja nur, weil
du in den App Store willst oder weil du Zugriff auf
Native Funktionen willst. Übrigens wisst ihr, was ich
letztens für einen Artikel gelesen habe?
Dass es mittlerweile Versuche
gibt über den
Beschleunigungssensor und
den
Vibrationssensor oder irgendwie sowas.
Gespräche mitzuhören.
Also sprich, dass Apps
ohne Zugriff auf das
Mikrofon, nur mit Zugriff auf
Bewegungs- und Beschleunigungssensor
Gespräche im
Raum
teilweise Wörter
decoden können.
Das ist heftig, oder?
Und Apps müssen
nicht fragen für Berechtigungen danach.
Ja, C++
hat nur keine Features für sinnvolle Sachen.
Wie zum Beispiel eine sinnvolle Stringklasse oder
so.
Aber ansonsten hat C++ alles,
ja.
Was auch toll ist, beispielsweise, was C++
auch nicht hat, sind sinnvolle Fehlermeldungen.
So. Starten
mal kurz die VM.
Irgendjemand meinte, dass
64-bit Raspbian ist jetzt.
Das heißt ja nicht mal Raspbian. Raspberry Pi OS
ist jetzt raus.
Was habe ich hier im Hintergrund?
Bing Image of the Day?
Was bin ich sehend?
Leute, was meint ihr, was das für ein Land ist?
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie
Schottland oder sowas mit Castles im Hintergrund.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Italien?
Könnte auch Italien
sein. Keine Ahnung.
Ja doch, das da hinten ist
ein Kirschturm oder sowas. Das ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich nichts.
Ach, was auch immer. Ist egal.
Also, was sagt ihr, dass 64-bit
Raspberry Pi OS ist da?
Schauen wir mal.
Imager.
Bam, bam, bam.
Loose OS. Mal gucken, ob das in dem Imager schon drin ist.
Hier ist noch 32-bit.
Raspberry Pi OS.
OSA.
OSA OS.
Wann ist denn das rausgekommen?
Das kann doch nicht so lange her sein.
Ach, hier, guck mal. 28 ist der erste.
Leid.
Okay, zwei Monate.
Eineinhalb Monate.
Ein Monat. Eigentlich ein Monat.
Sagen wir mal, ein Monat ist es ja erst her.
Ungefähr ein Monat.
Ist Italien. Nice.
Was mich an reinem C am meisten schört,
ist, dass man Character Arrays benutzen muss.
Wenn man C++ einem Namen
gerecht werden will, muss es ordentliche Strings geben.
Äh...
Der erste Satz hat mit dem zweiten
nichts zu tun, oder?
Also ich meine, weil...
Ja, Character Arrays,
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ist tatsächlich ein bisschen pain in the ass, aber
C++ Strings sind ja nur wirklich
so ziemlich die schlechteste Stringklasse,
die ich aus...
Mir fehlt keine Programmiersprache.
Mit schlechterer Stringklasse
in der Standardlibrary ein als C++.
Nix.
Da ist ja die Javascript DateTime
AP besser, als
die Stringklasse aus C++.
So, ich schmeiß mal kurz die MicroSD
rein.
Why is the Raspberry Pi OS Lite 32 bit
größer als the 64 bit?
Ist es? Zeig mal her.
Äh...
0,4G download? 0,5?
Pff.
Ist so krass effektiv mit 32 bit.
Keine Ahnung.
Hat denn auch die neueste C++-Version
Sachen im... Ja.
Das einzige, was sie geändert haben, ist,
dass mittlerweile, glaube ich, seit
C++...
14? Oder so?
Oder 19 oder sowas?
19 glaube ich. Ne, was?
20 gibt... Ach, keine Ahnung. Wir gucken einfach mal
nach. C++
String to Upper.
To Uppercase.
Wenn ihr mal kecken wollt,
wenn ihr mal wirklich lachen wollt,
guckt euch mal Stack Overflow an, wie man
früher in C++ einen
String von
Random Case zu Uppercase
gemacht hat. Passt mal auf.
Und das ist noch die schöne Variante.
Das ist noch die
schöne Variante.
Also, das geht noch viel
hässlicher. Das ist die
schöne Variante.
Die haben aber mittlerweile
To Upper haben die jetzt.
Ach, ich vergaß.
Ich hab
vergessen. Das ist ja
gar keine Methode mehr der Standardklasse.
Das ist ja gar keine Methode
der Stringklasse. Das ist ja wieder so ein
komisches Extrawurst
C++ Ding.
Guckt euch mal diesen hässlichen
Crap an. Alter.
Und warum gibt es String, Basic,
String, was auch immer.
String,
W, String, U8.
Oh, haben die jetzt tatsächlich
einen gescheiten, haben die jetzt gescheiten
UTF-8 Support? Wahrscheinlich
nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist
das einfach nur ein Byte Array oder sowas unter der
Haube. Guckt
euch dieses Elend mal an.
Alter. Ich meine, die haben
allen Ernstes keine
Methode in der Standard Stringklasse
für Uppercase und Lowercase.
Was ist
das?
Was ist das?
Die einfachsten Sachen sind in C++
so umständlich kompliziert
und wenn ich Standard C out sehe, kriege
ich auch schon wieder Anfälle. Wobei
eine gute Sache haben sie.
Die haben mittlerweile in C++
die haben
seit C++ 20, glaube ich,
eine halbwegs gescheite Stringformat
Geschichte in der Standard
Lib. Da kannst du jetzt nämlich
sowas hier machen. Standard Format
Placeholder und dann
hier den Kram einsetzen. Hier kannst du dann auch Sachen
drinne formatieren. Das ist übrigens
1 zu 1 von dem
Python Strings geklaut, wie das hier aussieht.
Ja.
Also sie haben es quasi geschafft
ein besseres Printf einzubauen nach
30 Jahren oder so.
Ne, ne, ne, ne Leute.
C++ keck wait, Alter.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Licht
einschalten. Glücklicherweise
muss ich dazu nicht aufstehen,
kann einfach in meinen Home Automation
Dashboard und schalte das Licht an der Decke ein.
Easy. Schon ist das Licht an.
Nice. Easy as fuck.
Nein. Standard ist
nicht die Standardklasse. Standard ist das Standard
Namespace, in dem der ganze
Müll drin ist.
Ja. Ja.
Das kommt ja noch dazu. Anonyme
Funktionen in C++ sind auch
Painschamp.
Gimp ist quasi das C++
der Bildbearbeitung.
Also ich persönlich bin ja bei
Affinity Designer und bei Affinity Photo
hängen geblieben, weil ich keinen Bock habe
mich in Photoshop einzuarbeiten und ich auch keinen Bock habe
Photoshop zu kaufen. Und Affinity Designer
und Affinity Photo sind relativ gut
von den Funktionen. Relativ easy zu bedienen
für Noobs wie mich. Und
auch nicht so teuer.
Kostet irgendwie, ich glaube 40 Euro oder so.
Na unter Linux läuft das
glaube ich nicht. Jetzt müsste ich mal gucken.
WineHQ
Gibt's das?
Garbage. Garbage
läuft das. Okay.
Dachte ich mir fast schon, dass das nicht
gescheit läuft mit Wine.
Wer will sowas auch unter Wine verwenden?
Garbage
läuft das.
Oh geil!
Es gibt Workarounds, um es zu installieren.
Aber nicht, dass es läuft.
Wo wir dann
dabei sind, warum ich eben
Linux VM unter Windows zum Laufen habe.
Ganz einfach, weil
ich unter Windows das Zeug mache, was ich unter
Linux nicht machen kann und dann in die Linux VM switch und
da den Kram mache. So, by the way, ich wollte meine
SD-Karte kurz
Ne, Moment. Was wollte ich jetzt
eigentlich machen, Leute?
Zack,
ich bin verwirrt.
Ne, die SSD.
Die SSD wollte ich
formatieren und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Zack, wo habe ich denn die SSD hier?
Die
Samstart.
Das ist eine SanDisk
Extreme. Eine
SanDisk Portable.
Nein, eine SanDisk
Extreme Pro.
Portable SSD.
Alles klar.
Poggers SSD sozusagen.
Massive Pog.
Also das einzige, was wir jetzt testen werden,
weil Leute, ich merke schon, mir tut es im Hals
schon langsam wieder jucken und
kratzen.
Was wir jetzt machen ist, ich haue
das auf die SSD drauf
und dann
und dann boot ich den Raspberry Pi und gucke, ob es funktioniert
und wenn es gut ist, freuen wir uns.
Und dann machen wir das nächste Mal
irgendwas Sinnvolles damit.
Ich wollte zum Beispiel mal wieder ein bisschen Ansible
basteln und gucken, ob ich den ordentlich
automatisiert kriege, das Einrichten.
So, Vierer. Choose Storage.
SanDisk.
Warte, warte mal, Leute.
Chat, war irgendwas wichtiges auf der
SSD drauf? Ihr wisst es doch immer besser als ich.
Ne, das war die, die wir für
Unraid zum Testen hatten. Da ist nichts wichtiges drauf.
Right. Yes.
Das Bitcoin Wallet.
Ja. F. Jetzt ist es weg.
Guck mal hier, gleich flutscht es
auf dem Drive.
Hat das Probleme mit dem Schreiben?
Zack?
Nö. Sieht gut aus.
Keine Probleme.
Preparing to write.
Discarding Exist... Warum
dauert Discarding Existing
Data so lange?
Ach, der downloadet jetzt erst.
Ach so.
Writing. Gib ihm!
Hallo, das ist
eine SSD mit 1500
MB die Sekunde.
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe es nur an USB 2
Anschluss angeschlossen. Ah, dann.
Aber ich meine, 400 MB.
Alter, was ist das denn?
Das ist ja slow.
Slow...
Oh, ach ne. Okay.
Er gibt Gas.
Warte mal kurz.
Chat, was gibt es sonst Neues?
Gimp ist das
C++ der Bildbearbeitung.
Ja, könnt ihr mich zitieren mit?
Gibt es das noch?
Ey, du kannst ja gerne Gimp verwenden.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin mit Gimp nie
warm geworden.
Nice.
Ja, aber 2018 ist nicht aktuell, oder?
Letztens eine VM mit
virtualisierter GPU
aufgesetzt und es funktioniert einfach richtig gut
und relativ einfach.
Aber nur mit Windows Server, oder?
Auf dem Desktop macht
Hyper-V doch immer noch Probleme.
WSL 2 hat doch eigentlich
Linux VMs abgelöst.
Naja.
Wenn damit gescheit grafische Programme gehen...
Ich weiß, dass es theoretisch mittlerweile gehen sollte.
Dann hast du immer noch das Problem,
dass ich am liebsten halt i3 als Desktop verwende.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, ich bleibe bei meiner Linux VM.
Hat die so
orange Akzente mit einem Loch in der Ecke?
Genau.
Die hier ist das.
Portable SSD Extreme.
Die ist orange mit einem Loch in der Ecke.
Genau, hier.
So sieht die aus.
Ja, jetzt wo es
DNS-Sperren gibt,
wir sind ja hier auch alle nicht in der Lage
DNS-Sperren zu umgehen.
Da brauchen wir schon mal eine Offline-Kopie von.
Passwortanalyse mit OTP-Support
deiner Wahl. Ganz ehrlich,
ich bin bei KeePass hängen geblieben
und ich verwende KeePass immer noch.
Und KeePass hat auch ein OTP-Plugin.
Also du kannst damit zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung
machen ohne wirklich einen zweiten Faktor.
zu haben.
Stimmt, das kommt dazu.
WSL2 ist ja mittlerweile VM.
Dementsprechend ist es halt mit Nested-Virtualisierung
und sowas da drinnen auch schwierig.
Also, ich meine WSL2 in einer VM dann.
Hab meinen Unify-Controller auf Raspberry Pi
aktualisiert. Jetzt hängt er schon seit Tagen
im Data, in der Database-Migration.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Deswegen
ist es ganz praktisch, wenn du vorher
einen Snapshot von machst.
Und zumindest mal
ein Backup.
Oder wenn das Ding im Docker-Container läuft,
dass du es zurückrollen kannst. Relativ easy.
Wobei du wahrscheinlich auch downgraden
könntest. Aber ein Backup von den
Configs ist auf jeden Fall ratsam.
Ey, du kannst ja auch von SSD booten.
Das probiere ich jetzt gleich mal aus, ob du das findest.
So. You can now remove
SSD-Card from the reader.
Naja, okay.
Es ist zwar keine SSD,
aber wir lassen ihm das mal durchgehen.
Wo war die SSD
am Start-SDB?
Mount, mount, dev,
sdb1
nach mnt.
Und jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, Leute. Muss man das noch machen?
Touch ssh?
Dass der Raspberry Pi beim booten ssh startet?
Oder startet der mittlerweile automatisch?
Muss man noch machen?
Warum eigentlich?
Eigentlich ziemlich blöd. Warum ist denn
sowas nicht standardmäßig drauf?
Naja, okay.
Passwort ist halt kacke.
Vielleicht ist es doch ganz gut, dass es
standardmäßig nicht drauf ist.
Okay, unmount.
Ne, umount.
mnt.
Jaja.
So, und jetzt guck ich mal, ob mein Raspberry Pi startet
damit ordentlich. Ihr werdet es nicht
sehen,
weil ich keine Kamera anhabe am
Basteltisch. Aber ich sag euch,
ob es funktioniert.
Und dann
loggen wir uns mal kurz ein
und machen einmal ganz schnell
einen DD und gucken, wie schnell das Ding ist.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Router
aufmachen und gucken, was im DHCP
gleich reinkommt.
123456, huge Passwort.
Nein, ich habe ein anderes Passwort
auf meinem Router.
DHCP Server,
leases.
So, schauen wir mal.
Strom.
Wo ist der Strom?
Da.
Finde ich gut, dass der
USB-C hat mittlerweile.
Ah, nicht eingesteckt.
Jetzt aber.
Lul.
So, mal gucken, ob das
direkt jetzt mit der SSD
funktioniert. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Meint ihr, das geht?
Dass der von der
SSD bootet, ohne dass ich was mache?
Der Raspberry Pi ist frisch. Ich habe den
ausgepackt, vorhin,
vor dem Stream aus der Packung und
jetzt mache ich SSD dran. Also, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also, er blinkt
schon mal wie verrückt. Das ist ja meistens ein gutes
Zeichen für, wenn das anfängt grün zu blinken,
das Ding.
Ne, angeht er.
Bei mir hat sich
gerade eine Kiste eine IP geholt,
die heißt Sixhead.
Und ich weiß nicht mehr, welche Kiste
ich Sixhead genannt habe, bei mir.
Irgendein
Server, der Sixhead heißt oder irgendein
DHCP-Client, der Sixhead heißt,
hat sich gerade eine IP geholt, sehe ich gerade
in meinem Router. Da ist er. Der Raspberry Pi.
Da ist er. Nice.
Boah, das ist ja easy mittlerweile.
Das ist ja
mal ein riesen Unterschied
zu diesem Krempel, wie man es
machen musste, als es neu war.
Zack.
Einfach nur noch
SSD flashen und
anschließen. Nice.
Das ist gut. Das haben sie schön
gemacht.
Wie heißt das OTP-Plugin?
Boah, irgendeines von Github.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Es ist, glaube ich, auch kein offizielles.
Doch, ich habe mir noch einen bestellt.
Ich habe, also was ich
gesagt habe, was ich meinte, zumindest,
vorhin ist, ich habe keinen mehr,
weil ich den, den ich immer
für den Stream verwendet habe,
benutzt habe, um
meinen TV-Header-Server im Wohnzimmer neu zu machen.
Und jetzt habe ich mir vor zwei Tagen
einen bestellt.
Und er ist da.
Was? Mach mal Ctrl-Shift-X
im Raspberry Pi Imager.
Was?
Moment.
Ctrl-Shift-X
Oh.
Hidden Menu.
Bonus Level.
Das ist nice.
Und da kann man jetzt SSH einschalten.
Ah, tatsächlich.
Cool.
Das finde ich nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Credits an mich, bitte.
Wieso?
Hast du den Pull-Request dafür gemacht?
Ach nee, weil du es
im Chat geschrieben hast. Ja, pock.
Huge Credits. Credits given.
Okay.
Nice.
Update hätte ich mal vielleicht vorher machen sollen.
Jetzt mal ganz kurz gucken, ob die SSD
auch funzt.
1,8T
hat er fertig resized.
Er hat fertig resized.
Ähm.
Was wollte ich jetzt noch machen?
Irgendwas wollte ich vor dem Speedtest
noch machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, machen wir mal einen ganz ganz
easy mode Speedtest.
Ähm.
Def 0
Output
nach keg W Punkt bin.
Und wie schnell
ist er auf die SSD?
Ja.
Also ich mein für einen Raspberry Pi ist das durchaus
respektabel.
Kannst du dich nicht
beschweren.
War doch sonst kein Problem mit das Ding.
Ja.
Weil mehr
kriegt, mehr macht der Raspberry Pi
halt nicht über USB 3.
Aber ist doch in Ordnung.
Wollen wir mal
Temperatur gucken?
Ähm.
VC
GEN CMD
und jetzt Temperature
VC GEN
Measure Temp.
Ist aber nix. Das ist ja nix.
Na gut, der hat ja auch nur einen Kern.
Der hat ja auch nur einen Kern.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Da müssen wir mal
ein bisschen mehr. Ähm.
Da können wir auch gleich mal gucken, wie gut das aktuelle
Flir Case ist. Ist BC drauf?
Kein BC. Ull.
Also das ist die, das ist die
äh, einfachste Variante
CPU Last zu generieren, die mir immer einfällt.
Echo 2 hoch
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
gepimt nach BC.
So. Und das ganze
H-Top
Einmal,
zweimal, dreimal, viermal starten.
Bam. 100% CPU Last.
Stimmt.
Der kann ja jetzt AVX,
ne, mit den, mit den
64-Bit-Funktionen.
Ja, das ist auch, das ist auch
die V8-Variante.
Ja, das können wir auch nochmal install.
Stress.
Machst du Faxen.
Ich copy-paste
mir jetzt einfach mal deinen Befehl.
So, wie warm wird der
jetzt? VC.
VC GEN.
Measure Temp.
Oh.
Geht schon, geht schon ein bisschen mehr hoch.
Aber ist immer noch
vollkommen im Rahmen.
Ja. Der wird gar nicht
richtig warm.
Also ist absolut in Ordnung.
Für Vollauslastung.
Watch.
Nein, nein, nein. So was machen wir hier nicht.
Wir tippen.
Von Hand.
Watch.
Was kommt denn als nächstes?
LS mit ordentlichen Parametern
oder wie? Ne, ne.
So.
Doch, langsam
wird er ein bisschen wärmer.
Ach, geht. Geht.
LL ist nur ein
Alias auf
LS.
Okay, dann machen wir das mal mit
Stress.
Kill all VC.
Gib ihm.
Oh, das ist besser als mein VC.
Das ist besser.
Wir bringen die Kühler
in den Raspberry Pi was.
Naja, die meisten Passivkühler
bestehen der Luft nicht wirklich.
Aber ich habe dieses Gehäuse und das finde ich
ist wirklich gut und das bringt definitiv was.
Das habe ich jetzt bei dem anderen
Raspberry Pi 4 auch.
Für mich ist das beste Case.
Das ist einfach ein Alu-Gehäuse,
wo du innen drinnen
einen Wärmeleit-Pad hast,
sodass quasi die CPU an den
an das Gehäuse
ans komplette Gehäuse
ableitet im Endeffekt.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob es da Bilder
von innen gibt.
Ja, hier, guck mal.
Im Prinzip hast du hier so ein
Wärmeleit-Pad auf der CPU
und ergibt dadurch das über das ganze Gehäuse ab.
Schau mal, ob die CPU
drosselt. Ah, da drosselt nix.
Also, over
ander Wolten tut er auch nicht.
Äh, Measure, was ist denn das?
Speed?
Performance? CPU?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was braucht man denn für einen Takt?
Oh, das ist ja aber eine sehr schöne
userfreundliche Ausgabe hier.
Sehr, sehr pock.
Sehr pock.
Measure Clock?
Ist es Measure Clock?
Äh.
Jetzt?
00, alles klar.
Moment, wo kann man sich denn den Speed hier nochmal
angucken?
Äh.
Measure Clock?
Will mir fast sein, das war doch...
Measure Clock arm?
Ach, so war das.
Und woher weiß ich das?
Gar nicht.
Ne, der taktet auch nicht runter.
Ne?
Also, das Gehäuse ist hier
lauwarm.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht,
das Case. Kann man nix sagen.
Was, SUS, SUS-Status gibt's
auch.
Moment, wo gibt es SUS-Status?
Wo ist es?
SUS!
SUS-Status.
Last
SUS-Pen-Status 0. Aha, alles klar.
Was auch immer uns das
sagen soll. Ne.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin echt
begeistert, wie easy das Setup ist mit
USB SSD mittlerweile.
Kannst du dich ja wirklich nicht beschweren.
Ich mein, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Am Anfang musstest du in die
ähm, in die
Kernel-Command-Line was eintragen.
Dann musstest du glaub ich noch
den Bootloader nochmal neu
generieren lassen.
Also das, ganz am Anfang, als es noch
experimental war, war das
ein riesen Act
USB-Boot zum Laufen zu kriegen.
Jetzt ist das eigentlich ganz schick.
Kann man nix sagen.
Gut.
Ja.
Dann basteln wir im nächsten Stream mal wieder
was, würd ich sagen. Wird mal Zeit.
Also ich muss auf jeden Fall noch vier
Dosenleisten flashen.
Das können wir im Stream mal auf die Schnelle
machen, weil
der Chat guckt ja immer unglaublich
gerne zu, wie ich Steckdosenleisten
flashe. Ich glaube Steckdosenleisten
flashen ist eigentlich
das einfachste,
was ich im Stream machen kann,
was die meisten Leute immer
ultra begeistert.
Das, das,
vielleicht sollte ich mal Steckdosenleisten
flashing ASMR
mache oder sowas. Vielleicht geht das noch mehr.
Das müsste ich wirklich mal
hochladen dann mit dem Titel.
Twitch-Kategorie
Powersocket Custom Firmware Flashing
Also wie gesagt,
das Gehäuse bringt was. Ich finde, das ist das beste
Gehäuse und ist auch nicht so teuer.
Guck mal hier, das meines Case kostet 22
Euro. Das ist absolut in Ordnung.
Kannste nix sagen.
Nee.
Könnte man
machen.
Rackaxe aus dem Kopf.
Also ich will mich jetzt selbst nicht
zu sehr loben, aber
ich behaupte mal, ich
bin nicht der schlechteste,
was Rackaxe angeht.
Die meisten Leute hassen
Rackaxe extrem.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich mag
Rackaxe Magic.
Und wer
mal was mit Back References
und Rückwärtssuchen und sowas gemacht hat
in Rackaxe, der wird wissen,
es ist eklig, aber es ist
nice, wenn es funktioniert.
Also ich bin jetzt kein
riesen Rackaxe-Fan.
Wenn es sich vermeiden lässt, Rackaxe zu verwenden,
verwende ich auch kein Rackaxe.
Aber Rackaxe ist eine schöne Geschichte.
Rackaxe Performance
ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Rackaxe Performance ist gar nicht übel.
Es kommt aber drauf an, was du machst.
Aber die normalen Rackaxe-Dinger
sind gar nicht so wild.
Ja, das Problem hatte ich auch schon.
Es gibt ja jede Menge online Rackaxe
Hilftools,
Hilfetools,
mit denen du deine Rackaxe schön zusammenbauen kannst,
weil sie anzeigen, was sie matchen.
Und dann landest du bei
irgendeiner Rackaxe-Implementierung, die
bestimmte Features nicht kann.
Was machst du heute noch? Ich gehe jetzt gleich auf was essen.
Ja gut.
Der offizielle...
Leute, soll ich euch mal schocken?
Official E-Mail
Rackaxe
RFC. Passt mal auf.
Das ist der offizielle
E-Mail-Adressen-Rackaxe
Das ist halt wirklich
hardcore.
Okay, Amazon nicht.
Was ist denn hier los?
Und die meisten Leute machen sowas wie
non-creedy-match
at non-creedy-match
backslash
.
3 Zeichen
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Question, why?
Naja, so viel besser
ist das in einer Zeile auch
nicht, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in einer Zeile so viel besser ist.
Oh, ne.
Die Rackaxe-Seile ist gecrashed, Leute.
Oh, das ist
was für die Weeps hier.
Es hat gematcht.
Nice.
Was? Hast du schon mitbekommen, dass
Was? Nein.
Habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Vielleicht spielt
ich dann tatsächlich auch mal wieder
ein paar Runden Overwatch.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe da keine großartige
Hoffnung für.
Ich würde noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter
machen, dass das
non-creedy-match ist.
Wobei das eigentlich nur sinnvoll ist, wenn du Gruppen hast.
Sorry. Mal gucken.
Muss ich mir überlegen.
PvP-Beta is coming soon.
Overwatch 2 PvP late
April.
Was ist das für ein Held? Den kenn ich nicht.
Ich habe Overwatch schon eine Weile nicht mehr
verfolgt. Welcher Held ist das
hier rechts? Das ist Zenyatta.
Das ist hier Brigitte. Wer ist das?
Sojorn.
Kenn ich nicht.
Ach, da unten steht es doch sogar.
New Hero Sojourn.
Na dann.
Ist das der neue Jeff?
Ja, das ist der neue Jeff.
Das kannst du Overwatch aber wirklich jetzt nicht
kann man Overwatch nicht ankreiden,
dass sie das machen würden für
Pluspunkte sammeln
bei Twitter-Leuten. Overwatch
hatte von Anfang an
einen äußerst diversen
Charakter-Cast. Kann man sagen,
passt in die aktuelle Zeit rein,
aber Overwatch hat das richtig gemacht.
Ah ja, okay.
Einfach nur edgy, weil es sein muss.
Aber Overwatch hat das
finde ich richtig gemacht.
Bei Overwatch hat sich das nie angefühlt,
als hätte man auf Teufel komm raus
Diversity eingebaut, anstelle
wo es eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt,
sondern es passt zu Overwatch, es passt
zu der Story, die sie da drum gebaut haben
und es wirkt einfach nicht gezwungen.
Also ich finde Overwatch hat es richtig gemacht.
Wenn auch Overwatch nicht ganz frei
von irgendwelchen Shitstorms war,
erinnert sich noch einer an die
Tracer-Pornopose.
An den Tracer-Pornoposen-Shitstorm.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Zumindest Tracer hatte
eine Pose,
die einem Playboy-Model
nachempfunden war.
Und das hat die Leute natürlich
wahnsinnig aufgeregt.
Was soll das? Sauerei.
Haben sich total aufgeregt.
Und
dann wurde es aus dem Spiel
entfernt und dann wurde sich
noch mehr aufgeregt.
Das war auch so ein Ding.
Und dann, um nicht zu vergessen,
dann gab es noch auf Twitter
ein paar Leute, die gemeint
haben, als in dem
offiziellen Overwatch-Comic
rausgekommen ist, dass Tracer lesbisch ist,
weil sie eine Freundin hat,
haben gesagt,
das geht ja mal gar nicht.
Weil, und jetzt kommt die Begründung,
weil Tracer
ist ein Charakter, der
explizit für das männliche Auge
designt wurde.
Das geht nicht.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Leute.
Ihr habt alle so den
Arsch auf und ihr seid nicht
mehr normal.
Kein Witz.
Komplett durch.
Anstatt zu sagen, ist doch nice,
dass die quasi ihr
Aushängeschild-Character
sowas ein...
Vielleicht war es auch nur geplant
für Publicity oder so, weiß man nicht.
Aber anstatt, dass das eingebaut...
Was? F ist weg?
Oh, was jetzt? Geht wieder, oder?
Das war gerade komplett...
Es kommt komplett gedroppt, alles.
Komplett abgekackt.
Der Stream.
Max wurde gecancelt, ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal wieder
ein bisschen streamen und gucken,
dass ich meinen Hals so ein bisschen wieder dran gewöhne.
Vodafone, ja.
Generalslain, danke für den Sub.
Mal schnell schauen, ob wir irgendjemand
hosten können von den Leuten,
die es verdient haben.
Beziehungsweise die
irgendwas streamen, was ich mir jetzt gleich beim Essen
angucken werde.
Nope.
Keiner da.
Nö, keiner da.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Tschüss.